second talk so it's going to be
delivered by dennis vorotines sev
he's a senior data scientist at aura the
finnish startup and he will be talking
about
explaining machine learning models in
2020.
dennis the stage is yours yeah thanks
yeah now you should be able to see my
screen so yeah first of all
thank you for coming i'm really excited
to be here and present this material to
you
uh my name is denis uh and today i'd
like
to share so basically today i'd like to
share some thoughts on how to interpret
machine learning models with the modern
python tools so recently
i worked a lot with interpretation
machine learning
and i have some experience which i'd
like to share
uh let's start
yeah so uh i'm working as senior data
scientist at aura
we are making readings for well-being
which are capable for tracking your
sleep
and we are using this data in order to
improve person sleep and overall
well-being
our most famous and recent project which
i was involved is early code detection
based on the data collected from a ring
before that i was working at gta
research central field where i was
helping to detect anomalies
during steel manufacturing using machine
learning
i'd like to start my presentation by
asking a question
why do we actually need explainable
machine learning
how it can help data scientists to
achieve
his or her goals our goals and how it
could help
a company uh personally i ask
these questions uh the following way
so imagine where want to solve some
business problem
and when we're solving business problem
our main goal
is actually optimize profit or some
other metric
uh given a set of constraints uh
so we have some data uh we're creating
target
that we want to predict and then we will
use this target in our business process
uh unfortunately machine current models
cannot optimize profits as
is so we create this proxy metric it can
be for example binary
accuracy or log loss or anything else
and to optimizing this proxy metric
uh we claim that the model the pipeline
which achieved the highest score on the
hold out data set
uh probably the best model and we should
use this model in our production
settings
and now the interesting part begins when
we are collecting data
our collected data is not actually the
real world it's just
a representation of the wordless words
mapping
and by collecting some data we inducing
selection bias by default
by training our model only on subset
subset data of
all available data we're also using
other sorts of biases
we may create a bug in our pipelines
uh models are also just a mapping of the
data and
so on and so forth so at the end
uh we may end up in this situation where
our final metrics our final proxy
metrics such as
accuracy might be pretty good on the
hold out and test data sets
but in reality our solutions are sub
optimal so
they are optimal for our proxy metrics
but they are not optimal for our metric
which we want to maximize which is
profit or
any other utility metric that we want to
use
and for me uh the possible way to solve
this problem
is to actually to start interpreting car
models start to understand
what is going on under the hood in this
black box of the model
and for me this interpretation is just
the final
a final stage of before pushing positive
production
is to test our model is it actually
delivering what were expected it to
deliver or
just repeated towards some artifacts in
our
data set or a biases in the dataset and
this problem of bias is actually really
important nowadays
if you go to google and google ai biases
we will find a lot of articles
related to the topic and the society the
people
are really interested to understand that
the models
uh which were created as data scientists
are
actually not using these biases that
they're not biased in any sense
uh and also this topic of uh
interpretation of machine learning
models is quite popular in the papers in
the scientific world nowaday
so since 2010
we see an exponential growth in the
number of papers
on the interpretation of machine
learning which is
just pretty nice but personally i feel i
feel this gap
between what our researchers can show
us can write about and the actual data
scientists who are
who are creating these models and
pushing them into production
and for me at the place of
interpretation machine learning is
something between
uh evaluation stage of the ml
pipeline and deployment stage of the
machine learning pipeline
and i talked with a number of data
scientists who discussed
how they approach interpreting machine
learning models
what decisions they made after
reputation and so on
and i had this feeling that in reality
interpretation
is just a not very useful stage of
male pipeline you just calculate sharp
importance for every feature in your
data set you show
let's say top five most important
features to your stakeholders
uh they replied well that looks good to
me let's push it into production or
even uh even even they don't say that
it's
it's fine so it's probably uh model
knows best
uh this this this this idea is actually
taking from
the the paper called interpreting
interpretability
in which authors asked data scientists
uh what decisions they are making based
on the interpretation and it turns out
that
no matter what interpretations will be
shown to the
to the data scientists they are willing
to push machine learning uh to
production
no matter what so uh to check
if it's really a problem because
obviously it is a problem but
is it actually a real problem was just i
talked with the data science car not
very
into this field uh i decided to ask
the following questionnaire in the two
communities first one is
amalops community second one open data
science two very famous
um data science related communities and
the questionnaire was following so
select which describes you
or your company best three options first
one
we don't interpret our models or do it
occasionally
second option interpretation is a part
of our pipeline
but we only calculate sharp importance
and the third one
is that interpretation is a part of our
data science pipeline
and we use several models such as sharp
lime
gum pdp and etc etc
and it turned out that just six percent
of
um data scientists in open data science
out of
about 100 participants they answered
that they actually use something besides
shop
the vast majority of data scientists are
not actually
using any any tools or just calculating
shop so the problem which i
are described on the previous slide and
i believe there is a problem
uh why it is a problem because sharp uh
shop is great too
no doubts here it's probably state of
the art for finding
most important features for your model
but it cannot
by design answer other questions such as
uh what are the most important training
points in your data
or what is dependency between feature
and
prediction um globally according to the
model
and all other questions which are listed
on on the screen
and these questions they're actually
really important because when you're
trying to
interpret your model you try to
understand how it's making decision
you cannot only use most important
features because
it's not the only question you should
ask you should ask several questions
and that's why i'm actually proposing to
use the framework which i'm currently
using myself
so it's pretty simple uh it's not
perfect obviously but it's okay for me
at least
this consists of four main questions
which i asked dirk interpretation
and after uh answering each of those
questions i make a decision
uh should i rework this model or
continue to the next
stage of interpretation let's let's go
through each question step by step so
the first one
uh the first one is following do we have
the same metrics
across different subgroups and here uh
subgroups could
mean like anything it could be subgroups
based on some cohorts of users such as
gender race age we want our model to
perform
uh well enough on all of those groups
because
uh in our production settings we will we
are expecting to to see all of those
users
uh also subgroups could be some clusters
in the data
which are not related uh by by user race
for example or gender but related to
something else
maybe number of push chase or something
something else
uh and so the question that we want to
answer again
is that we want to see the same metrics
across different subgroups
if you are not seeing same metrics
across different subgroups
uh it might be a signal that you have a
bias in your data
and you try to find those bias and
remove it you
or it might be again an artifact of the
data set for example
uh the subgroups can be different and
that's why model
uh just find this difference between
those subgroups and
the the final results are because of
those differences
uh in that case if it's it's if it's
normal if it's not because a bias in the
date set
you may just create different models for
all those different subgroups
and commonly the performance of several
models trained
on different subgroups is better than
just
one model which fits them all
personally i use my own custom script
which just generate
report for predefined set of groups of
users and i just checked this course
manually
but i really like this idea which was
presented
by uh guys from uber
the library called manifold uh the idea
is idea is following so we train our
model
uh we train our model we are making
predictions for
our holdout data set and then uh
we cluster our data based on the
difference between
actual prediction and between prediction
and actual label so on the right part of
the screen here
you see um upper upper image
you see three clusters three segments
the x-axis is log loss and we see that
for segment number zero the
log loss is low which is which means
that for this subgroup of users
model performs extremely good for
segment one and segment two
log loss is higher and we may check
what why why model uh made a mistake
in in those subgroups uh and we may
again use manifold here
we say that segment 0 is group 1
segment 1 and segment 2 is group 0 and
we compare
different features based on
based on those different clusters and we
may see that for example
uh bottom picture feature number zero
uh has a different distributions
across two different segments and it
might give us insights on what should be
changed in our processing
or it might tell us that hey maybe it's
worth
adding a new model and train two
separate models for these two separate
segments of users the next part
uh the next question to ask it what are
the most important features
of the model and here we are checking if
the most important features are actually
expected
so what i do i before
looking into most important features i
just write down list of expected
features
and then compare it to the features
which are achieved by
by shop or any other tool why i'm doing
that
because if i'm not doing that you know
there is a risk there is a chance
of me uh doing hypothesis hypothesis
after
results are known it's not a
good bias and that's why i'm trying to
avoid this
making hypothesis after after seeing
results
because again in some cases you might
just say hey
well it's unexpected but it still looks
good to me so let's move on
and i want to avoid that uh yeah
so here this is pretty pretty
straightforward
the state of the art is sharp i
recommend to use it for finding most
important features
if you are training uh the tree-based
models such as light gb and mxg
pay attention to the gain importance of
your of your models
uh also uh you may find very interesting
library card called daleks uh this
library could provide you
the pretty pictures uh one of them are
presented on the bottom
part of the slide right right part of
the slide
so this this library is actually
calculating
very same output as sharp
but it is presented in a better way in
shop the output for
each local interpretations just log it
uh in
in daleks it's converted to
probabilities and i find this
plot more beautiful than than
one in um that the one is generating
shot and also
i know that some data scientists are
using
lime for both global and local
interpretation
sometimes i don't recommend to do that
because slime has
a lot of problems uh like three problems
three but
very huge problems first one is that the
fidelity of lime interpretation is
really low fidelity is an accuracy
of of of your surrogate model in our
case in the case of lime
so the the accuracy of surrogate model
is not high enough
that means that interpretation is is not
also
very accurate and the second problem of
lime is that
interpretation are actually based on the
choice of hyper parameters
so depending on what type of parameters
you are going to choose in life
you may end up in a situation where you
have just contradictory
interpretations which is not a derived
desirable property of interpretation
tool
and the third problem is that that
interpretation uh depends on the input
um a lot so if you change input even
slightly
you may have a different interpretation
so
interpretations are not robust towards
small
distortions in the input many
interpretation tools have
this problem but live has it's like
in the worst uh worst possible
state next question to ask
so we determined most important features
now it's time to find what what is
uh the dependency between feature and
target and prediction according to the
model
and again we're checking if our
dependencies
seems uh okay to us we're checking if
dependency
does not uh have these bumps and beats
because
this again symptoms that you have some
problems with with your data
and there are several tools uh to do
that uh
i reckon i personally use uh accumulated
local effects
in alibi library but partial dependency
plots are good
is a good choice as well so we recommend
to pay attention to those stuff
and also the library called interpreted
it's just a brilliant idea i
really like this this library i used it
quite quite a while
so this library cannot
make your models interpreted instead it
is trying fully
interpreted fully white box models from
scratch and the idea is following so
in in in all models in machine learning
uh we're training
model a function function f which takes
all input features and create and try to
create this function which
which predict the target in additive
models
we are doing quite a different stuff so
we create
a separate function uh for each input
feature
and these functions this functions f1 f2
fn they called shape functions
uh and then of course we just combined
the results of the final predictions
just a
combination of all of those shape
functions output of
those shape functions and
the the huge plus of this approach is
that
by doing so uh of course we're not
taking into account
intersections between features which in
some cases is is very good for our of
i'm sorry very bad for our problem but
by doing so
we actually could inspect each of those
shape functions and and understand how
uh how this particular value of this
feature affect the final prediction like
what is contribution of this feature
which is pretty similar to the shop but
this is done in very good
theoretical manner let's put this way
this way and this
interpreted library it's quite accurate
it's fully
fully white boxes you may see a
benchmark
uh on several data sets compared to xd
boost random forest
and results pretty good actually
even taking into account that no
intersections between features were
taking into account
and the most important part here is that
we actually could inspect again those
shape functions that's why we started
using this library so uh
right part of the screen we call our uh
explainable booster classifier we train
it
we ask it to show most important
features and for example in this task
we may see dependency between
output of the shape function and
h i believe in years so we may see that
between
20 and 70 years the shape function seems
quite nice and we might understand this
dependency but after 70 years um
the the shape function is not um
is not smooth it's just jumping uh up
and down
for example here for 80 years
for 80 years the output of model will be
zero
but if you are 79 it would be something
like
plus one and if you're 82 or 83 it will
be plus
0.5 0.5
uh of course it's not desirable we want
our
uh our shape functions to be smooth
and it is a sign that probably in the
training date we don't have enough
uh training points and we we may correct
actually this shape function so
we set uh this part of
of shape functions of shape function and
for this part we may just plot a
straight line
uh it's it's it's not possible
uh out of the box unfortunately but i
think you got the idea
so by doing so we actually improving our
model even further
we're not only explaining but even
improving our model so we
we change this part with a straight line
the part after 70 years and
we may retain our uh our
other other shape functions or
we may keep the results as is and push
model to the production
the last part but not least is to
check how we should change the input so
it would classify as another class
and the general idea here is to
understand
uh so we train our model we make
predictions for the validation data
and generally it's a good idea to check
uh on what examples
model made a mistake and what features
contributed to that mistake
i talked about it previously one way to
do it is to use manifold
but other ways to do it is to take each
point separately
the points with the highest difference
between prediction
and the target and to find the closest
point to the given one but
with correctly predicted class and
compare
uh future values of those points and it
might give you some insights
of the uh of the separation
curve of your of your model and what you
may do in order to improve
to improve your model uh so this idea
again i'm using my own custom screen for
that i'll explain later why
this idea is presented in the google's
what if tool
um so this tool basically do what i
described
right now and it may also show you some
metrics across different subgroups
it may show your partial dependencies
plots for different features which is
also
good good um attributions of this
dashboard but the main problem that
this google slot if tool works only with
tensorflow models
of course you have random forest
gradient boosting in tensorflow well i
believe you should have those
but uh i prefer to use light gbm i
prefer to use cad boost and it's not
possible to do
to do that using this tool uh also
you may use um variants of
control factual instances and this is
actually a smart idea
so the idea of this controversial is is
following so
though those methods are only applicable
for models
to which you may calculate gradient uh
well basically it's neural networks
and when you're training neural network
uh you have fixed input you have fixed
output
and you are updating weights of your
neural network
uh in order to minimize the distance
between your prediction and your target
when you are explaining your model on
the other hand
you want to reverse this task so now the
model is fixed
and you want to find such input which
maximize or minimize the
output and this is a smart idea no
doubts
uh because neural network especially if
it's a well-trained neural network if
it's
model like oracle model or with 100
accuracy
it might find the instances right after
this
separation separation curve the problem
is that
it is an iterative process and even
after few iterations of this
optimization
you may your points may end up in the
spaces
uh where you have no training points at
all so basically
to that in the space when where points
are
unprobable in general so maybe you want
to
uh optimize credit score and output of
your model could be
well you have to work 50 days
a week or something like that which is
just not possible
but for from models output it is
possible
uh the idea of um this
same uh albeit like last example
on the slide uh is that you just
you you say to your model well you may
actually optimize you may
update your input but please be in the
specified
a circle around this point game it is
good idea
but it doesn't work i tested several
times on my own tasks
and i just end up in the situation where
the output is
far away from from from the
initial input of the model and
this whole idea of working with
gradients is
looks very similar to the adversarial
examples so these
control factual examples are actually
adversarial examples
uh but for explaining and uh
making this adversarial examples for
your input for interpretation well
i'm not very fan of of this stuff yeah
so this is all from my side uh thank you
for your time thank you for attention
uh this is link for a presentation and i
will be happy to answer your questions
all right thank you so much dennis for
the presentation it was really
interesting
and yeah we have a couple of questions
in the chat
and i guess we will start with a very
interesting one it's a kind of
philosophical question so ari is asking
how do we know
that understanding machinery model in
general is possible for humans
what does it even mean well it's
actually a great question and what i
specifically like about all papers
related to the interpretability
is that uh very very good papers
start by asking what does it mean to
interpret that model to the person
and i don't think it's just a question
to which may we may find an answer
uh because it's really too complex and
there there
couldn't couldn't be any any um
exact answer uh
but i don't think you're satisfied with
this answer so
personally i believe that if you may
um process if you may
copy the exact steps of the processing
as model did that means you understand
how
it works so basically if i may uh
reconstruct the predictions that means
that
i can recreate them what does it mean so
for example
uh deep neural network with 100 layers
with million of parameters i cannot
calculate
all mathematical formulas or i cannot
calculate all
output of each layer and so on and so
forth uh
in limited amount of time theoretically
i can do it
but in reality i cannot but if we're
using
let's say logistic regression with five
input features
i cannot multiply each input feature by
its own weight
and produce an output and in this sense
i cannot and i can understand how this
model
works so it's probably my answer to this
question
all right okay so
let's move to another question so andras
is asking
how can we use these techniques for
large and high dimensional data
good question when you are working with
large data set generally it's a good
idea to take a subset of your data set
for example you may start by trying a
small model
on a subset of data set or you may use a
subset of data set
for explaining your model uh how to
select the size of this subset
well that's pretty straightforward you
need to find the such subset of data set
after which output of your
interpretation tool does not change
and commonly it might be just 10 percent
of your data
again it's task dependent but
it might it may be really
small workable the amount of data which
fits in
rob memory if i'm talking about working
with
a lot of features uh
i think generally it's a good idea to
run some sort of feature selection
or work only with most important
features when you are
running interpretation for example
if your model consists of 10k features
i bet not 10k of them are the most
important but
only maybe 20 something like that and
you must have a lot of time
by working only with those 20 features
but again it's a real task dependent
all right okay so we have another
question from tommaso he's asking
uh he thinks that those attributability
tools
are only working for tabular data and
where we have clearly defined input
features so what about entry
for other settings for example in the
sequence
classification problem yeah
my my presentation was mostly about well
it was fully about tabular data
uh except last part but anyways so
there are tools which can work with
stable rattles which
can work with nlp data with text with
computer vision with sound
with videos but personally
i don't work with those types of input
data and that's why i didn't present
them
uh in them in my presentation but i
recommend
just to go through our most famous
uh tools for interpretation such shop
you may check lime
uh alibi and those tools could provide
you
approaches how to deal how to integrate
computer vision uh like what are
what are most important parts of the
picture uh texts like what
are the most important part of the
sentence and so on and so forth so it's
possible to interpret
this um non-tabular um
tabular data tabler input data
and there was um second part of the
question
wasn't it yes for uh for example
sequence sequence classification problem
how can we
interpret um
um
well it actually depends it's a hard
question
i believe that uh every input data can
be
uh every every model every uh every type
of data can be
interpreted if you are talking about
sequence data
we probably may use uh again
it depends on type of the model that you
use if you are using
some sort of gradient boosting machine
for classifying
uh your input sequencing or just a goal
point by point you may use
the same tools uh which i listed here
but i would like to add some
constraints so basically you cannot
change
the interpretation
like dramatically so too similar to two
close points should say
should have same interpretation if we're
talking about
uh sequence classification
using deep neural networks well there
are a lot of works
uh in which afters using attention
layers
in order to find what a part of the
input sequence
contributed the most uh towards um
towards final prediction like to which
part of the input sequence
model pay paid more attention so
basically answer here
use attention use um transformer
architecture to
to to find those uh attention maps
all right maybe another question in the
same context so
eva is asking if there is any this tools
for explaining nlp predictions
again i'm sorry i'm not working with nlp
a lot
uh i would recommend still
check sharp it should work with text
and alibi two libraries both are
mentioned both were mentioned in my
presentation
yeah i guess as mehran ali is is
commenting here he said
as long as it's future importance based
on the feature target dependency
i guess we can apply this this kind of
tools right
yeah it's actually probably a good
question
uh can we apply the same strategies uh
for
unsupervised models for example if you
are doing
a clustering analysis question analysis
can we use the same logic for finding
most important features
well sometimes it's not useful for
example in car means there
are no important features but we may
transfer
the task of of unsupervised learning
uh in supervised approach so basically
for example we cluster our data
why not to fit a model to predict the
cluster label
and if the accuracy is high enough that
means that we may
inspect this supervised model uh and
find what are the most important
features
which affected these like
different different clusters and also
there are a couple libraries
which can work with interpretation tools
from like
with on with some supervised models are
probably i worked with
isolation forest the tool which allow
you to find
what are the most important features for
isolation forest
solution forest is a tool for finding
anomalies in your data
um and probably that's it maybe
there are a couple other tools well
yeah all right yeah some people are
asking about the slides
are there available after the event i
guess you have this link here
with this qr code does it redirect to
your
github or uh it's redirect circular to
the presentation yeah
okay all right cool and for people who
are interested in
getting the slides for olgojan
presentation
please email him at augustan well
he he mentioned his email in the chat so
feel free to reach out to him for
for the slides okay let's see if there
is
any other question uh
yeah we have another one from vladislav
he's asking
is it possible to automate the
interpretation if you are training
number of models in other words
do the explanations require a human to
make the decision in hyper parameter
optimization
or model selection
well there are actually two questions
first one can we optimize model training
and
answer is yes uh we may use different
tools for hyper parameter optimization
personally i use optuna
to do hyper parameters because well
general people cannot work in the high
dimensional space of choices for hyper
parameters such as for example
for a lgbt number of trees uh
depth of your um of three
and number of lists and stuff like that
models
do it much much better so the answer for
the first part of questions yes we can
automate this and you should do that if
you're not
already doing that because it will
improve scores of your model
uh by dramatic margin if we're talking
about interpretation the things are
quite tricky here
uh generally in the industry for example
if you're looking at
automated machine learning tools such as
h2o
that robot google after medal
uh what else yeah i think three is
enough
so these guys they're actually trying to
add
a sharp importance calculation uh for
for the pipeline
of making the model and generally i
don't think
it's a good idea and well it's
it's a good stuff to have this but it's
not uh
good stuff to pay attention to why i'm
thinking this way
for me model interpretation is is not
optimizable
at all because it is a work in which you
should make hypothesis and test them
using several tools
and i don't think that this automation
of hypothesis making and testing
is uh is incapable of of current state
of
automan yes of course you might complete
shot importance but
still it's not answering some of your
questions you may
create this partial dependencies plot
automatically again this is good stuff
but i you actually understanding
why you're using these tools like why
you're calculating these most important
features why you're
uh making this partial dependency plot
maybe it's not even useful in your task
maybe you should use another tools so
for me again i'm sorry that i'm
repeating myself but for me
interpretation
is just making hypothesis about your
model
and try to check this hypothesis uh with
um with the tools which are available to
you
all right okay i guess
we don't have any other questions but i
guess i have i have one
quick one question so what is your take
on the
the bayesian deep learning for
interpreting deep learning models do you
have any
thoughts on that wow
it's a it's a it's a hard one
right at the end of the presentation to
be frank um
i'm not very familiar with bayesian
neural networks
a year ago i took part in the us burbank
ai conference it's a very famous
conference in russia
and one of the presenter was uh i
believe his name is gennady
vietrov he is extremely famous in
scientific
or so-called extremely famous person uh
who spent a lot of time
um working with bison neural networks
and
with neural networks in general and he
presented um
a comparison of different approaches how
we may
calculate uncertainty in deep neural
networks
and i didn't understand a single word he
said uh
if you slide because it was a pure
mathematics but
i understood the following so i
understood the final results so
if you want to calculate uncertainty uh
in
deep neural networks the best idea the
best approach you can take
again might be just my understanding
because i'm completely wrong here we
just like cut this
out uh during post processing so uh
the the general idea was that
if you want to collect uncertainty you
should train a lot of
runs of the same architecture with the
same data
but with different choice of random seed
and then just average your predictions
and calculate let's say
average and standard deviation that will
give you uncertainty and estimation
it is not an answer to your question but
i think
it will provide you some uh
understanding of what i'm thinking about
uh the rotation using deep neural
network so
it's a hard topic and i'd like to see
some results which could
work out of the box and some people who
are already
worked with such
such models and then apply it in my
own work because i'm not researcher
well i do some research this research
work but i don't want to spend
months of research uh when i have a lot
of projects
to be done all right
thank you thank you for the answers well
i guess we still have one
last question from ali he is asking what
are your thoughts about
simple decision trees or association
rules for interpretation
uh it is actually a good idea to have a
simpler models
instead of complex ones generally
speaking
unfortunately there are not too many
tools which
can allow you to do this stuff of
interpretation
out of the box but i i really like
the following framework which i will
describe now so the idea here is that in
our training that
well commonly training data is large
right we have
thousands of examples in our training
data but very few of them are actually
useful
so a lot of examples in the training
data are actually just the same
same examples but slightly different
features
and we don't need too much training data
in order to fit our algorithm right so
the idea is that
we we may find the most important
uh training examples in our training
data
and then using a small uh
like smaller version of our initial
training that train
a much simpler model and this approach
it was tested uh it was tested using uh
the sharp
so in in sharp approach uh you calculate
the contribution
of each feature in the final prediction
but the same approach could be
applicable for training data as well
just calculate contribution
of every training instance towards final
loss and select uh the instances with
the highest contribution and
then we train your model on those uh
smaller amount
on smaller training data and the
researchers again
if you want to link to the paper just dm
me in linkedin
the researchers found that when we are
using
smaller training data but carefully
selected
and simpler models we may have
well not better model but quite quite
compatible models
compared to these complex ones and i
believe
this this approach is quite robust uh
quite quite good to have in your data
science toolbox
unfortunately there is no tools uh there
are no tools
which can allow you to do it out of the
box and you need to write this code
yourself
and this is greatest limitations of all
all right thank you so much